[Musique]
nous sommes sans communication avec
elodie moore mcnicoll et les toons
élèves finissants de l'école secondaire
thérèse-martin à joliette au québec au
canada bonjour et le dis comme un
sauveur merci d'avoir accepté cet
imprévu pas par ces moyens virtuels ce
que tout à dire toi c'est ainsi donc que
ce merci quand même
elle dit je finis dans secondaire sept
semaines après le début de la semaine
prochaine c'est la fin d'une longue
période d'étude des commandes suivi ça
dans le contexte de la pandémie se
tenait à l'école et je vais pas jusqu'à
la fin mais voilà on me dit ça
évidemment un trou chez l'humain comme
moi j'ai vraiment adoré mon nicole
dumont a fait est ce qu'il y avait mêlée
sans que tu crois maintenant pouvoir
tirer de cette expérience parce que on a
beaucoup parlé des scénes et on a
beaucoup parlé même des jeunes sans fin
mais on a peu parlé des adolescents est
qu'elle ait senti je peux tirer de cette
expérience en tout cas et les disques et
antarctiques chez tes amis mais je vais
mieux
comme vous l'avez dit laissant un trou
et oublié puis on aime travailler
surtout en lui lançant trimestre par
rapport aux âneries mentale des enfants
une sociaux mais selon moi ce qui aurait
été la plus affectée que cela passe par
des mineurs
parce que s'il avait fait ça parce que
comme tout le monde à ces empires à
l'intérieur de nous
ou encore j'ai tapé fort de beaucoup
d'années les nikon souhaite savoir si
l'enfant fut évidemment au chant
scolaire
l'attaquant belge y foncez pas été
convaincant tant qu'à faire comme un
pape noir évidemment c'est fini ça
m'étonnerait pas de voir naître des
tensions et seulement comment
s'entraîner il monte avec que genius qui
pourrait mal à place à la peur de se
morfond puis chienlit ce vaccination
mais on doit vraiment aller de l'avant
puis trouver une solution aller chercher
les personnes ressources
ça c'est forcément beaucoup d'avantagés
comme ça aille chercher les personnes
face aux jeunes est allé en mode
solution utile fait une belle laissant
finalement québec tirait tout cela crie
pour un peu s'adapter à ta manière aussi
toi et quelques amis vous savez lancer
un projet un projet pour souligner cette
fin
des secondaires cette fin d'études un
nouveau un passage du son à l'âge adulte
ou aussi pour la plupart d'entre vous
donc parle de ce projet que vous savez
lancé toi et tes amis ensuite envoyé que
les écoles des photos ou encore paul de
trucs soutenu la fête selon martin ont
été condamnés par rapport aux bains
c'est totalement faux sur dans un avis
séparé du marche qu'au québec pour moi
parce que c'est quelque chose qui est en
face à beaucoup de talent mais et les
derniers jours il est juste allé au
revoir et merci à notre merci ce n'est
pas sa principale qu on les a côtoyés
finalement longtemps qu'ils ont d'abord
donc on essaie de placer la borie fort
est d'avoir un bon regarde pas dans les
faits je voulais juste que vous savez
contacté le gouvernement québécois a
fait des députés aussi de la région dont
vous vous levez donc vous savez penser à
une journée à dédier une journée partout
au québec pour les finissants cessa
examen depuis enquêteurs ont même
traversé ce foutoir
ça va mal pour notre école la plus
injuste pour lui en tant qu il ya sur le
100 m a dit je viens de dire est bon
qu'ils auront beaucoup à pied dans ce
premier projet ou minéralisation une
substance roberge
puis on a eu des réponses possibles
comme ça il s'avère cette journée là
pour maintenir mon mieux mais ça départ
à manuvie canada
on l'a pris comme ça world gérer mais la
macif une bataille à tort elle a dit mme
houle mcnicoll je te souhaite beaucoup
de chance pour tous que ce un bien pour
toi est vraiment beau projet que vous
savez le site web et sami où vous êtes
tous en fait toutes ces les finissantes
1 de l'école secondaire thérèse-martin
de joliette ici au québec au canada
merci beaucoup et le dit
[Musique]